By now, you probably know that the NSA can track your every move online.
If you care about your privacy, and want to know what data the NSA has collected from you,
then you should know what a FOIA request is.
The Freedom of Information Act, or FOIA, gives you the right to request access to federal agency records,
and the right to get those records.
But only if the records don't fall under one of the nine exemptions that keep them out of the public eye.
So you can actually FOIA your own data.
That is, you can make a request to see which of your own data the NSA has collected.
So far, everyone who has attempted a FOIA request for this has been denied.
But do you think you have a right to know what data the NSA has collected from you?